So here's the solution to this quiz in case you had any problems.
The first thing you have to do is import the SK learn regression module.
Of course it isn't quite this simple because it's called sklearn.linearmodel,
but you can figure this out from the documentation pretty easily.
There's a familiar linear regression function, and
I have my regression which I named reg.
Reg gets, linear regression, and
then I don't have to worry about parameters in this particular case, and
then the next thing to do is just to fit it the same as we did a classifier.
We do this of course on our training data, and of course now we have this
regression its been, trained on our training data and we're just returning it.